pourtant les animaux compagnie joue
vraiment un rôle extrêmement important
dans ces moments d'isolement tendance
aux personnes âgées
alors on se pose la question est-ce
qu'ils peuvent constituer un danger
justement pour leurs propriétaires et
bien un peu plus tôt cette semaine la
présidente de l'ordre des médecins
vétérinaires du québec a publié une
vidéo sur youtube dans laquelle elle
donne vraiment des conseils intéressants
en fait est très utile pour les
propriétaires d'animaux de compagnie on
va en voir quelques observions c'est
présentement plus que jamais faut dire
que le coroner des russes se transmet
d'humain à humain et qu'on peut donc
développé la maladie mais qu'en est il
pour les animaux bien n'y a aucune
évidence scientifique pour le moment que
les animaux peuvent contracter la
maladie est la donnée aux humains
cependant attention des gens qui sont en
isolement et qui vont aller promener par
exemple leur chien on pourra les prendre
un peu l'air et de lui faire faire ses
besoins bien et il faut être conscient
que si le chien rencontre quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui a le coronavirus mais il
ya un risque que cette personne dépose
on pourrait dire le virus sur le pelage
de l'animal en le flattant et ça il peut
vivre sur le pelage de l'animal pendant
un certain temps alors l'animal peut le
transporter et donc comme ça il devient
un vecteur et peut le donner à son
propriétaire voiliers sont on n'y a
peut-être pas pensé alors c'est
important de garder une distance entre
notre animal et d'autres personnes
également ce pas juste pour les humains
la distanciation sociale et si une
personne qui est atteinte par exemple
lakovic de 19 son animal ne devrait pas
entrer en contact avec d'autres
personnes
alors combien de temps un justement est
le virus peut être actif vous rappelle
quelques données que vous avez
certainement entendu alors dans l'air il
peut être actif pendant trois heures sur
du matériel comme le cuit pendant trois
heures également sur le carton 24 heures
c'est pas bien c'est un pensez-y si vous
recevez par exemple des colis par
livraison et sur le plastique l'acier
inoxydable regarder ça peut être comme
ça pendant trois jours c'est pas rien
alors voilà
l'ordre des médecins vétérinaires qui
rappelle aux propriétaires d'animaux et
chris paul temps d'aller voir son
vétérinaire pour un examen annuel de son
animal aller seulement vraiment voir un
vétérinaire qu'en cas d'urgence alors
impôts festif réduit partout on voit là
exactement et la présidente de leur
disais justement que les médecins
vétérinaires contribuer justement à
réduire les effectifs dans leurs
cliniques mais ils sont là bien sûr si
vous avez une urgence pour votre
adversaire et c'est bon ça répond à des
questions de plusieurs plusieurs
personnes ce matin merci michel